what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today don't have
coffee but i got water some morning
water thoughts before i start don't
forget like the video that helps with
the algorithm subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification bell and
sign up for memberships because i do
have these coffee half of these coffee
thoughts i post to members only so if
you want to see
members only yeah okay so
today we're talking about a girl that
accused me of something recently it's
called
that apparently i hate women
so i'm gonna let me elaborate
what did i find so
just tiring sometimes dealing with these
girls so
the other day there's a girl that came
on my show and she was kind of wild now
every time she's coming my show she's
kind of wilded out and i don't i don't
mind if girls are acting crazy on my
show i mean i make more money off of it
like what do you mean obviously that's
entertaining she's very entertaining but
she was just saying some wild things on
a podcast so clearly
you're going to get clipped
i don't know what you expect if you're
one of the most entertaining people on
the podcast we're probably going to take
clips of what you said and we always
link the full video so if someone wants
to go back watch the full video they can
and this girl was particularly mad that
she was particularly mad that we said
that women date bad boys and then
complain
because she proceeded to cry on the
podcast about dating a bad boy and then
you know she's complaining later and i
said to her
that's what you did
like you're paying yourself out to be
the victim when you had a nice guy you
didn't date him then you dated the bad
boy and then you complain and
i'm not knocking her like but i didn't i
didn't make you do anything on your pa
on my podcast so what happens and i've
noticed a pattern with women women will
come on the show they'll say some crazy
[ __ ] they'll get clipped cause
and then they'll blame me for the
actions that they took even though i've
had hundreds probably
of women that have come on the show and
nothing really happened
um i've also had men same thing happens
to them they say some wild stuff they
get clipped i always
sometimes i forget but i try to include
the full video description right in the
description and the
the men
always take accountability they might
not come back they might not appreciate
it but they don't come in and blame me
for what they said out of their mouth
but this is a common theme that i always
get from women and now this girl
she's wilding out even more i gotta i'm
trying to find this dm
someone like sent me a dm that she's
sending to other people
where is it
let me
um
i swear i was just looking at it but
basically saying though that i hate
women
she gets dumber the more she watches my
content but you're watching though
and and that um yeah apparently the
biggest thing is that
i hate women and so
now now the question is
do i do i hate women and this this is
how i feel about it okay i love women
enough to tell them the truth
because what happened today is there
we keep bailing out women for bad
decisions and it doesn't help us in the
long term it helps us in the short term
in our 20s right i'm in my 20s right but
i've just always been a long-term
thinker
so
you're gonna tell girls to sleep around
even though men are repulsed by that
[ __ ]
okay you're gonna tell girls that even
if you get pregnant you should get an
abortion
one in three women that make over forty
seven thousand dollars per year has had
an abortion
and forty percent of women that have had
abortions it's their second or third so
what we're seeing is women making bad
decisions and being bailed out every
single time and what i'm tired of is
seeing women
destroy what should be a stable family
for their bad decisions
people used to get pregnant they used to
get pregnant in high school and then
they'd have a shotgun wedding
and they'd still build a very beautiful
family over it but now we're telling
women to leave and be happy
that living a life by yourself is more
fulfilling and having a career is more
fulfilling than a family
and i get a lot of slack often because
they'll say you're not married and
one you guys have no idea what i'm doing
behind the scenes okay
because if there's one thing that i've
learned is keeping your dating life as
private as possible but i'm telling you
that will be a priority in my 20s i am
looking to get married in my 20s
and
a lot of women just want to party it up
until they're 35 and just expect the
same results
and so what women do is one they'll
either flip the script and be like what
about you
and when i when i'm not even telling
them what to do okay i'm saying these
are the facts data and statistics move
accordingly do whatever you want but
if you move that way and you come back
later
and
and it doesn't work out for you
don't don't come crying later i'm a big
believer in everything that happens to
you in life is your own fault big
believer okay i i've been in a
relationship i shouldn't have been with
it was my own damn fault because i made
that decision
so i'm not gonna go around blaming man
i'm not gonna go around hating men
forever i'm not gonna go around
acting crazy and blaming it no no i made
that decision and i'm just so tired of
women blaming every their decisions on
everyone but them
that's what i'm so tired of it's your
own damn fault and
same with this girl if you're gonna oh
here it is i found it i found it
um
someone sent her the clip right
and sometimes i stop bullying these
women off my shows it's not
these clips aren't meant to bully people
it's meant to expose how women think
and hold anyways
um i hate myself somehow that's why she
doesn't like women okay let's start i am
very insecure i will say that i'm not
overly confident but it's also because i
feel like i'm just an average looking
girl
and i think it's okay to be average so a
lot of people take that as insecurity
but i just think it's just like i'm
normal i'm a normal person i'm not
nothing crazy
and
this is just the attitude that we see
from women is like
you hate yourself if you don't think
you're the world revolves around you you
don't think that
like your [ __ ] don't think stink all of
a sudden like i don't even think i'm
insecure i think i'm just realistic but
like that comes off as insecure to women
nowadays because we're so used to being
coddled
other things she says um the more
i watch the dumber i become
and then this girl had the audacity she
calls me
she's talking [ __ ] for like five minutes
okay
saying i do all of these things and i
say you know what
then don't come if you're going to
accuse me of all this fine we won't have
you back
but ma'am the why why are you dming all
these people off my show like it's just
like an attention
but this is what i'm tired of i'm tired
of seeing women older than me acting
like they're 12. like people say why do
you do what i do i have a lot of reasons
for why i do what i do but one of them
is i'm so tired of 30 plus year old
women or women that are almost 30
acting like their [ __ ] don't stink has
nobody humbled you in this life oh my
god thank you god i have siblings to
make fun of me
like
even um
like that's what i'd be thinking
sometimes i'm like i'm 25.
you guys are older than me and you still
act like this
and that's the thing is it's not hating
women to recognize where we have our
problems it's not hating women to say
that we need to improve in these areas
it's not hating women to say these are
the outcomes for these decisions and if
you continue to make these decisions
they might be the outcome and you know
what if you get that outcome don't
complain later everything in life is a
trade-off
and there's things that i have traded
off like i
i don't
i want to say i could have been married
to 21
i didn't prioritize getting married at
21 right and right now i could be a mom
with four kids i'm not
you know part of me kind of wishes i was
but all you could do is look at the
facts data and statistics and move
accordingly
and the other issue i have is a lot of
rich people
that like i grew up in the one percent
right but a lot of one percenters are
pushing a one a luxury lifestyle onto
average women so
if
if i went around pushing women to get in
vitro fertilization when the average
woman makes 35 000 for per year and sure
maybe my family could afford that but
what is the average girl going to do
that's a luxury that is a luxury and you
guys are moving like you are rich and
you have something to fall back on when
you don't and i think it's sad and i
think it's dishonest and i don't like
that
so all you can do is give women the
facts data and statistics and move
accordingly the other thing i guess like
can you ever be wrong
absolutely i could be wrong
there are facts there's stats that i
learned on the show that changed my
opinions on things if you watch my two
years of content where i'm reacting to
[ __ ] i didn't always like these truths i
didn't always like the reality but i'd
rather live in reality than look like an
idiot living in delusion and that's what
i'm so freaking tired of and it doesn't
mean i hate women i love you enough to
tell you the truth
and you can do with it what you want i'm
not i don't even i don't even consider
myself an advice channel because i
really don't tell women what to do i i
give them the facts i give them the data
that i know and tell you to move
accordingly so if you don't wanna
if you don't wanna do that if you wanna
continue blaming the world for your own
mistakes
then
don't don't put that on me for hate for
hating women put that on yourself
for making poor decisions and own up to
your poor decisions and the thing is
this is another thing that men women
don't understand about matt is that men
will accept a lot and overlook a lot if
you come at them humble
i know men that have dated and married
single mothers i that is not their first
choice right to date and marry a single
mother but that single mother came at
that guy out of perspective of i don't
deserve you and she treated him like
she didn't deserve him
and like a lot of guys don't know what
that feels like
instead they get a single mother that's
entitled
that acts like she's better than them
well of course you're not gonna get good
outcomes then but
do i think it's over if you're a single
mom no you can still get married but
it's important to be realistic and come
at those guys like they are doing you a
favor because they are
and honestly i think people kids should
just date each other leave us on
leave us out of that leave us out of
that nonsense
but
that's the truth behind it so do i hate
women
decide for yourself i guess don't forget
to like the video subscribe bring the
notification bell i'll talk to you next
time bye